hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we have a review of
the second episode of fire force the
heart of a fire soldier and it's safe to
say that this is not really what I was
expecting from a second installment
after last week's very action focused
first outing but I very much enjoyed
what episode 2 delivered because it was
such a stark contrast and demonstrated
that hey this series could actually be
capable of some decent emotional depth
and I'm really glad that fire force took
this turn so early on because I feel
like it was important to highlight the
humanity of the infernals rather than
continuing to see them as
monster-of-the-week sort of threats for
too much longer I mean in my review of
the first episode even I called them
fire demon II things and that term
greatly oversimplifies matters it makes
it quite easy to see them disposed of
whereas in this episode dealing with the
infernal was such a painful and
heartbreaking experience because what
they're forced to do is essentially
euthanize someone and of course the
whole episode very much centers around
this idea that company 8 are not some
sort of special combative unit but more
of a group who are expected to perform
this incredibly emotionally draining job
and implement actions that nobody else
can or should ever be expected to do and
once again this was absolutely not what
I was expecting even when they arrived
at the scene and everything was all
quiet I was still thinking that things
were going to get out of hand and very
destructive very quickly and then we cut
to the infernal sitting politely at the
table which was actually quite funny for
a second because at that moment my only
experience with these things were
violent and energetic however the true
tragedy of the situation struck me very
shortly after it was incredibly simple
but super impactful and I feel like this
specific case is something that's going
to carry over with me to future infernal
cases because from here on out I can't
think of them as anything but
exceptionally tragic humans so things
are getting very interesting from a
moral perspective and that was also
highlighted by the whole idea of keeping
your weapons concealed in public and
through the extended shots of the
victims daughter very very well done our
last tragedy is not the only focus of
this episode though because we also have
the introduction of Arthur Boyle who
seems to be the rival character for
Shinra and he brought a lot of fun stuff
to the table including some great comedy
that was sorely needed to balance this
episode out I have to say that initially
I am much more intrigued by his overall
design and character than I am generous
though although a lot of that may have
to do with the fact that you know almost
any character who wields a sword let
alone a plasma blade automatically
skyrockets in terms of favorability with
me and also after only one episode I
don't feel like I've had the proper time
to really bond in any way with Shinra I
mean yes we've seen a glimpse of his
tragic
but just over 20 minutes of screen time
isn't enough to stop another protagonist
type from swimming in and capturing a
bit more of my interest and Arthur game
into things very quickly so quickly that
I really hated the opening of this
episode because he just appeared right
in front of Shinra and a conflict of
sorts started to it Shinra seems to yell
and then promptly get cut off as the
opening credits begin playing which and
I cannot emphasize this enough was
jarring as hell I honestly think it's
one of the worst pieces of editing or
direction that I have ever seen and I
don't mean the whole opening sequence a
lot of it was quite beautiful I just
mean the cut to the opening credits this
just is not how you start an episode or
how you do anything it was just so
jarring and off-putting I feel like a
much better way to have gone about it
would have been to have Arthur appear
before Shinra then cut to the close-up
of him saying yo devil or even after he
says that he's here to slay a devil and
then hit the opening credits cutting
shinra's hole bit about taking it
outside altogether or finding a way to
include it after the opening maybe
because it simply does not work the way
it's presented and it is a huge stain on
this otherwise fantastic episode and
getting into more of said fantastic
episode there was a brilliant fight
sequence featuring Maki absolutely
owning both of our rookies which I
really appreciated
primarily because it showed off her
pyrokinetic abilities which I was very
curious about last week and it was just
great to see her kick some ass and there
was a nice bit of comedy in there with
the whole ogre thing and she just seems
like a nicely rounded character at this
stage fun to watch great in action and
cool abilities what more can I ask for I
am particularly intrigued by her power
should provide flames of what appears to
be some sort of sentience I don't think
it was explained in the episode maybe it
was and I just missed it but it was an
absurd the cool power and it makes me
wonder if she could do the same to
greater levels and quantities of flames
and you know essentially crafted
Godzilla scale fire dude bro that is
completely under her control suppose
we'll find out there was also a tiny bit
more if he namah this week and I'm still
not entirely sold on him he's just so
damn intense that intensity is played
for some decent laughs SIA and so I'm
looking forward to learning more about
exactly what his deal is the star of
this week to me though was definitely
Aki taro and his constant display of
competent leadership despite having no
fun fire related abilities he strikes me
as by far the most important member of
company eight due to his supreme
decision-making and ability to easily
read and interact with people the latter
of which is a heavily underrated trait
and one that I don't think any other
member of company 8 has because they all
seem to have that one feature that gets
them into some sort of conflict whether
it be serious or comical mainly comical
at this stage
but stuff like he knows extreme
seriousness Oh monkeys foolishness and
tendency to overreacted certain words or
even the lack of life experience of
Shinra and offer they all make
interacting with others difficult at
times and a Qatari seems to have that
special something that allows him to
easily read people and situations very
enviable I wish I had anything even
remotely resembling that kind of
awareness and judgment next up we were
also given hints of a greater evil this
week with the introduction of the guy
face whether he's a legitimate big bad
or some sort of lesser bad I have no
real opinion or inclination to guess on
right now but he has a cool enough
design I suppose kind of like a phallic
card from Helsing and cross from D
Grayman at a secret anime love child but
finally this episode also drops the
concept of the rookie fire soldier games
which smells an awful lot to me like the
beginnings of a classic shown in
tournament at the moment I suppose I'm
picturing something kind of like the
Sports Festival in my hero academia but
this should be a lot of fun if only for
the fact that I imagine we'll be getting
to meet a whole ton of characters from
other companies which is great because
I'm two episodes in and I'm already very
very eager to explore this expanded
build in a bit more depth and get a feel
for what other kinds of people are out
there as well that's what they're
capable of video look in essence episode
2 has me even more sold on this series
than the premiere last week it is shown
that fire force isn't necessarily at its
best with big over-the-top flame written
action pieces but that it can also
handle quiet and powerful moments with
incredible impact and as a result I will
be eagerly awaiting next week but that
pretty much does it for episode 2 of
fire force if you enjoyed this video
when the content this channel produce in
general then please do consider donating
to the new world review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps support this
channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
ori takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on the episode this has been
the new world review and I'll see you
next time